前回の話はほんの少々
あのまたもう一回繰り返してまとめて考えますけど
あの前回はこの無因心という十八があると言ったんですね
アヘートゥカチットと言いまして
あの無因心 無因心は十八種類あるんだと
で 因は無いと 因は無いと言ったって
仏教の因果説にも関係ない
突然偶然現れるところかということはそういうことではなくて
アビダンマでは アビダンマでは因というのは善悪を決める原因は因と呼ぶんですね
ですから 我々の行為が
我々の心が不善心か善心か
清らかな心か汚れている心かと
それを決める尺度がアビダンマでは特別な用語で因と言うんですね
それはヘートゥと言うんですね
でも因は一般的な意味では原因の因だから
別にそれとは関係ないんです
でもアビダンマでは特別にこの善悪を区別する原因として使ってるんですね
そこで四つがありまして
貪瞋痴と浮貪浮瞋愚痴という
それはもう一応もう聞き慣れていらっしゃる言葉なんですね
そのアヘートゥカチット十八種類の場合は
無因心十八の場合は貪瞋痴もないし
浮貪浮瞋愚痴でもないんだと
だから無因と言うんですね
ですから この十八種類の心が
あの善心でもないし 不善心でもないんです
あれ いい心だとも言えないし
悪い心だとも言えない
ただ単に心ということで
で そこで その十八をまた三つに分けて
一番目はアクサラヴィパーカですから
アヘートゥカ 入りますけどね
アヘートゥカ アクサラヴィパーカという心が七つで
七つでアヘートゥカ アヘートゥカ
アクサラヴィパーカがまた八つで
で またアヘートゥカ 次は三つで
そういう風に十八が出来上がっちゃうんですね
そこでこの このアヘートゥカ
アクサラヴィパーカ七つはどっちですかとか
まあこの前全部一つ一つ説明いたしました
で その中でまあ一応こんな数字とかね
まあきめ細かく覚えておいたっても
そんなに役に立つわけじゃないんですけど
まあ一応まあ仏教道徳的な
あの まあ理解だけあっても構いませんし
アクサラヴィパーカ アクサラというのは不善で
不善という意味で ヴィパーカっていうのは
まあ無垢で 移熟ですという意味なんで
移熟心とか言ってますからね
だから無因であって 不善移熟心かな
まあそういうテキストにありますからね
まあその言葉が で これはどういうことかというと
人々が まあ生命がいろんな悪い
まあ悪い行いをする 人間の行動は何でも善か不善かともう簡単に二つに分けてしまっちゃうんですね
で なぜならば人間の 人間だけではなくて
生命の行動 いわゆる諸動が
諸動は まあ貪瞋痴か浮貪浮瞋愚痴かどっちかに入りますよ
ですから まあどんな行動にしたっても
それは善行為か不善行為かというふうに二つに分けられるんです
そこで不善行為をすると
それなりの結果が味わえなくちゃいけない
行為には結果があるということで
それで不善行為の結果として
この無因不善移熟心七つあるんだと言ってるんですね
で この中で出てくるのはもう何と言いますか
チャックヴィンヤーナ
ソータヴィンヤーナ ガーハヴィンヤーナ
ジールハヴィンヤーナ
カーヤヴィンヤーナという五つが出てくるんですね
チャックヴィンヤーナというのは眼識で
目の働きで それから耳識で耳の働きと鼻の働きと舌の働きと体の感覚としての働き
五つあるんですね それは不善の行為の結果の場合は
この心が働いてるんだと
まあそう言ったらなんか分かりにくいんですけど
まあ我々人間として物を見たり聞いたり感じたりするんだけど
いつでも自分の気持ちのいいものを見たり聞いたり感じたりするわけじゃないんですね
で いつでも美味しいものしか味わうことはないということじゃないんですね
たまに全く美味しくないものも味わわなくちゃいけない
見たくないものを見なくちゃいけない
聞きたくない音も聞かなくちゃいけない
体で感じてほしくない痛みやら
そういうものも感じなくちゃいけないし
そういうのはまあ途中途中あるものなんですね
いつでも人間にはもう美しいものだけ見えて
美しい音だけ聞こえて
まあもうすごい気持ちのいい香りだけ嗅いで生活することはできないんですね
体の感覚でいつでもすごい最高に気持ちいいんだという状態にはいられないんですね
あっち痛いこっち痛いとかね
まあ歩いたら疲れるし
座ってたらまた疲れるし
ですから 痛みやら苦しみやらも体でも味わったりするんですね
そこでこの その自分としては気持ち悪いものを見たり聞いたり感じたりすると
それはアビダンマでは不善
瞋恚 意地悪心だと いわゆる不善行為の結果だと
というふうに考えられるんですね
で そういうことはまあ我々はもう毎日
毎瞬間瞬間 この五根を使ってるんですね
眼耳鼻舌身というものは
体でものを感じない瞬間がないんだから
眼でものを見てない時がないんだから
目を開けてるたびにものは見ているんですね
耳があるたびにあるんだから
いつでも音があるたびに聞こえてしまっちゃうんですね
そこでいろんなものが耳に聞こえるんだけど
たまにうるさいと感じたりするし
たまに人があまりも音に敏感で
ものすごくストレスになっちゃって
神経質になってる人もそうでしょうし
たまにひどい病気になるまでになっちゃうでしょうに
ただ単に音なんですね
ですから そこは個人の差がありますけど
なんかすごい精神的なもうイカれちゃったんだというある人が電話もあったんだけど
何ですかというと まあ夜も道路でオートバイですか
暴走族が もう別にそんなまあ夜は結構音は聞けるだけのことで
まあそれにある音なんですけど
ある特定の人々がそれによってまあ治療しなくちゃいけないほど神経に関わる関わりがあるかもしれませんし
そんなことはもう何のことなく
駅のその真ん前でアパートを借りて住んでいる人々もいるんですね
だからもう二 三分ごとに電車が通っていくんだから
それで安いアパートだったら
電車通るたびに建物がガタガタするし
もう何のこともなく平気でいる人もいるし
ですから この その個人差がありますけど
そこで問題はその個人がこの目に入る形と耳に入る音と体で感じるものにどんな味わいをしているかとということなんですね
で その神経質の人々いるんですね
例えば人がこの歩く時は足でもちょっと引っ張って歩く時はものすごく気持ち悪くなったりとか
怒ったりしてもういい加減にしなさいと
しなさいという場合もあるし
いくらうるさくしたっても何のことなく平気でいられる人もいるし
そこで我々は聞く音を見るものについて気持ち悪くなったりする場合
苦痛を味わう場合は 心の明るさか明るさが消える場合は
それは不善意熟心だと理解した方がわかりやすいんです
もっとわかりやすく言えば
これはもうこの前行った悪いカルマの結果だよと
ものすごい俗っぽくにそう考えた方がもっとわかりやすいと思いますよ
ですから 私たちは過去生で
もう過去生でもいいし
今生でもいいし 悪い行為をしているんだけど
そんなもう覚えてないんだ
そんなもう悪い結果は全然味わってないんだと威張ることはできないんです
1時間以内で聞く音はこう分けてみると
すべての音が気持ちいい音ですかというと
そうじゃないんですね
別に聞きたくない音はいっぱいあるんです
その中で ですから その聞きたくない音を聞くたびに
それは不善 不善の行為の結果として
悪いカルマの結果として見た方がいいんです
音に対しても同じこと
で ぐるぐる変わっちゃうんですね
このアヘートが腐敗パークの場合
また同じ 5つあるんですね
ウペッカーサハガタ チャックヴィンヤーナ
ソートゥンヤーナ ガーヴィンヤーナ
ディグハヴィンヤーナ
カーヴィンヤーナ で スカサハガタカーヴィンヤーナというものがないか
あったありますなんですけど
ないんです で そちらにまあ 5つがあるんですね
それでまた眼耳鼻舌身の働きなんですね
もし我々は眼耳鼻舌身で認識するものは認識して
それは別に自分に対しては気持ちいいもので
別に逆らう必要はないんですね
見て 別に見たくないという気持ちは起こりません
そういうものは過去の善行為の結果になるんですね
ということは 人間はカルマからは全く逃げている
自分を隔離して守っているということはありえないということなんですね
カルマの結果から いわゆるアビダンマで言うのは
我々は見ること 聞くこと
味わうこと 嗅ぐこと 体で物事を感じること自体はカルマの結果であると
いわゆる体あることは
体自体あるでしょうに
ですから 体自体あるということはもうカルマの結果であって
というふうなことになるんです
で そこで人間の社会では
この自分が過去生でいいことをしたんだからと言ったりしたっても
そんなにいいことをしたならばいい結果ばっかりでありますけど
そうでもないんですね
まあずーっと我々はもう悪いカルマもいいカルマも
まあめちゃくちゃもう経験しているんですね
例えば例えば 1 分間自分の感覚を見ておくと
1 分間の感覚の中でも一部がもうありがたい感覚で
一部はありがたくない感覚っていうのはあるはずなんです
ですから 善と悪は我々はいつでも混ぜ混じって経験しているんです
善のいいカルマの結果だけ味わう人はいませんし
悪いことばっかり味わう人間はいません
結構極々の感じで味わってますし
それで極々ではなくて
少々いいいいカルマの方が多い人がすごく幸福だだこうだとか威張ったりしていて
ほんの 50%よりほんのちょっと低い人は自分が不幸だ不幸だと言うだけのことであって
そんなに大したことないんですよ
私たちの目から見れば大変幸福な人だと思う人にと人もかなり苦しみを感じているんです
まあいろいろ大変なことはありますから
で それでカルマから今人間よくやることをものすごく食欲があったり
贅沢したかったりして
強引に贅沢しようと 強引に体楽しめようとやっている人々いるんですね
もう食べる時でもものすごいうるさくて
これは食べない あれしか食べないとかね
まあ北向いて食べない
南向いて食べないとか
いろんなこと言ってるんですね
本当にレストランのウェイターがね
なんとか色で 例えばもう黄色い色でも聞いてたら
そのレストランで私は食べないここですよなんとかとか言ったりしたり
もう何でもくだらないこと言ったりしてね
まあそういう食べ物に対してすごくもう執着があったりすると
贅沢をするんで とにかく自分が気持ちいい環境で食べよう食べようと頑張っちゃうでしょ
音に対しても いつでも綺麗な音だけ聞こうと
もう必死で苦労して探し求めて聞いていると
そうするとどうなるかというと
自分のこの死ぬまでのカルマのいいものを全部まとめて拾って使っていることになっちゃうんですね
で 後で残っているのは悪いところだけ
で それから全部もうまとめて味わらなくちゃいけないんですね
ですから だから仏教ではまあ落ち着きなさいとね
小欲知足で生きていきなさいと
あんまりあちこち探し求めるなと言っているのは
まあ一応我々は 80年間生きているならば
80年間も同じレベルでいた方がいいでしょうし
そこでもう 18歳から 35歳まで最高に幸福を味わって
36歳になってくると糖尿病やら高血圧
ありとあらゆる病気で悩んで悩んで
もうそれからまあ 45歳になっちゃうと歩けない状態になって
車椅子でベッドでもう 80歳までもう生活するということはもうそんなに幸福だと思えませんだけどね
そうでなく まあ別に楽しいということもないんだけど
楽しくないということでもなく
まあごく普通の生活であるならば
もう死ぬまでは健康的で生きていられるんです
それは自分がカルマの使い方なんですね
ですから 日本でもこのいろんなテレビで紹介しているでしょ
このすごい長生きしている人々なんかは
かなり長生きしている人々を見ると
まあ私たちよりはすごい性格はしっかりしているわ
あまり贅沢はしないし
もう食べ物にしても まあむちゃくちゃ貪って食べるわけじゃないし
まあそれなりに適当ないいものというか
自然的なものなんか食べて
まあよく運動して ごく普通の生活をしているんですね
それで目がよく見えるわ
もう歯がまだまだちゃんと残っているわ
耳が聞こえるわとかね
もう貪って自分がいいカルマを食べてしまったわけじゃないんですね
ですからこの そういうふうなことで
我々にはこの現に身心にはどれぐらい力があるかということはもう決まってるんですね
そこを全部使い過ぎたら
もうもう二度と使えなくなっちゃうんです
ですから 体をあんまり楽しませちゃうと
このいろんな体の病気として
高血圧とかいろんなことで出てくる
目耳鼻やらをあまりにも楽しませちゃうと
大体そこら辺は鈍感になってしまうだけのことで
そんなに苦しみがないかもしれません
それでも目が見えなくなっちゃったらかなりきついでしょうね
生まれつき目が見えない場合はもう慣れてるんだから
暗闇の生活には これもう中年になったところで目が見えなくなっちゃったら
まあ大変きついんですね
もう生活できなくなっちゃいますから
ですからこの まあ年取ってくると
大体目が衰えて耳が衰えていくということは
もうカルマのエネルギーもどんどん終わっていくということなんですね
まあそういうのはまあ仏教的な解釈でというか
アビダンマ的な解釈なんですね
大体まあそれぐらい覚えておけばいいんで
そこでこのサンパティッケナサンティールナという心 2つ上に入っちゃうし
それで 7つになります
2番目のアヘトゥカプサレヒパークの場合はソウマナサーガササンティ
ールナウペッカーサーガサンティールナサンパティッケナという 3つが入って8になっちゃうんです
で そこでまあ 15種類のあの全部
悪の結果 で そこでだいたいそれぐらいで似てるんですね
で これでアヘトゥキリアという指差しに三つあったんです
指差しっていうのは単なる行動だけ
行為だけ カルマ的な結果がない
これもカルマ的な結果がないんだけど
これ結果なんですね カルマのそういう結果得たらそれで終わりと
これは結果ではないならば行為なんですけど
行為だけであって結果はない
結果ない行為 だからそれを仏教ではなんか不思議に扱っているんですね
なぜならば 全ての行為に結果があるんです
結果がないものはないんです
それなのにただの働きだけの働きもあるんだという
こういう 3つの心がありまして
それはまあ パンチャドゥア
パンチャ何でしたっけ？で
パンチャドゥアラーワッジナチッタマノドゥアラーワッジナチッタンという
えーと 何でしたっけ？五門因縁心
五門因縁心という 2つあるんですね
五門因縁心というのは
この眼耳鼻舌身に心が現れようとさせる心なんですね
いわゆるいつでもなんとなく我々は敏感でいるんですね
耳がいつでも音を受け取ろうと頑張っているんです
目もすぐ反応しちゃう
その反応の心なんですね
それが五門因縁心というのは
五門因縁心っていうのはここの中の反応なんです
それはものすごい速くて
もう説明するとかなり難しいんです
そこら辺は で だいたいその 2つの心とだいたい 3つぐらいの心で
この現代心理学の世界での心理学分析は全部その 3つしかの心にしか仏教でないんだからね
だから説明するとかなりしんどいと思います
ですから まあそこら辺は置いといて
で  18番に出てくるのはこの笑喜心という笑う心
で 笑う心の場合も これは一般の人々が笑うと
それはほとんど欲なんですね
楽しくて笑っちゃいますから
ですから人が笑うと欲だから
貪瞋痴だから罪なんですね
笑って結構罪を犯してるんだ
で この俗世間で言うほど仏教心理学的な生き方っていうのはちょっと難しいんです
普通だったらよく笑いましょうと
明るく生きましょうと
その方がもう願望になりますよ
病気になりませんと言うんだけど
アビダンマから見れば笑ってる連中はあんまりの欲ばっかしで欲ばっかしで生活しちゃうと必ずひどい目に遭うんです
いわゆる不幸になってしまっちゃうんですね
だからもうただ単に勝手にもう笑っちゃえばいいということじゃないんです
もし笑うならば 無欲の心で笑わなくちゃいけない
それはこの大心であったんですね
大心が説明しましたね
あの善不善心 善心は  上心だけですよね
上心 この上心 上心8説明しましたところで
このソウナッサハガタ
危惧の心が 4つありますと
その心で笑うならば それは善行為でいい結果が出てくるはずなんです
いわゆるむさぼりのない心で笑うのはいいんだけど
むさぼりの心で笑うとそれは悪なんですね
ですから笑って笑っただけで
まあ病気になって元気になるっていうことでもないんです
でも普通の人にはだいたいそこはなかなか難しいんですね
笑っちゃったら そこに確実に欲が働いているということもありますから
じゃあそこでこちらで笑喜心というのは
こういう一般の人の笑い事ではなくて
この覚った阿羅漢やお釈迦様や
そういう聖者たちの笑顔
笑い方なんですね その聖者たちも笑うんだと
笑うんだけど 単なる行為だけであって
何の結果もない いわゆるもうカルマには全然結果がないんだからね
もうそれは心の中の態度がもう全く変わってるんだから
ですから もう笑うときも
我々の目的で笑うわけじゃないんです
ああ 今日は美味しいものをもらったんだ
楽しいんだというふうに笑うことは全くないんですけど
まあ一応阿羅漢たちの笑い方を説明するためにそうなってるんです
そういう心が入ったまま
お釈迦様はいろんなところで笑いましたということを記録しているんですね
そこで説明しなくちゃいけないんですね
アビダンマの専門家が
だからこういう心を入れたでしょうと思いますけどね
だからそういう まあとにかくこのアビダンマっていうのは
まあそんなにこの そんなに完全な説明でもないんです
その経典で 仏教テキストで出てくるものを
まあ適当にいろいろ心分析しただけで
自分たちが気がつかなかったものはそのまま置いていっちゃうっていうね
例えば現代的な心理学的な分析は全く興味なかったし
人の心はどのように動きますかっていう
一般的にはね それ興味なかったし
それよりは人の心はどう成長するかっていうことはすごく興味あったんですね
いわゆる精神的な病気な人々のことは全く考えてないんですね
現代人にとったら もう人間っていうのはノーマルレベルにはなかなかなりくはないし
みんなノーマルのレベルより以下のレベルで
いろいろうつ病やら縁起精神やら
もう精神的にすごい苦しんで悩んでるんです
ですから 心理学ではこの精神的な病気の人々の科学になりまして
この宗教をなさっている人々っていうのは
もうそんな病気じゃなくて
もうかなり一般の社会はまあ捨てていっても
すごい高いレベルのことを目指してたんだから
その高いレベルの心には興味あったんですね
まあ親が亡くなって 自分の結婚した相手が死んじゃっても
すごくもう落ち込んでるんだと
じゃあその人の心はいかがなものかと
そんな勉強興味なかったんですね
まだ昔っていうのは 別に精神的な病気の人っていうのは
もう全くなかった時期だからね
ですから 昔っていうのは
こういう人は最近ですね
もうこの精神的なおかしい人
人っていうのは一般的になっているのは
ですから そういうのはないんですね
アビダンマでは もし昔も今みたいにすごい精神的な
いろんなコンプレックス
コンプレックスどれぐらいあるかというと
コンプレックスもコンプレックスになってるぐらいコンプレックスですからね
で いろんなコンプレックス持ってる人々がいたならば
そこら辺説明するだろうと思いますよ
だからといってアビダンマでは説明できないわけじゃない
それは全部貪瞋痴の働きで生まれるものですから
その働き自体だけはないんですね
どんな煩悩かっていうことはあるんだけど
じゃあだいたいこういうふうにアヘートゥカ・チッタは18があります
それはこの前の説明で
今日は違う業の で 今はとにかくこの18種類のカルマとして結果だという心の説明をします
それ15はカルマ として結果
3つはただの働きだけ
次に じゃあ人がいいことをしたら
どんな結果かとまた言わなくちゃいけないところ残ってるんですね
あの大善根というし 善根とも言うし
なんですかね いろいろ言葉あるんだけど
このもう一回 この情信にまた戻るんです
この情信の場合は この
情信は一応説明しました
情信というのはこの 貪瞋痴ではなくなって
不貪不瞋不痴で人々は行動すると
それは大変ありがたい行動で立派なカルマなんですね
大変善根なんですね そこであの情信と呼ぶんです
80あります 不善根の場合は
あの貪根瞋瞋根痴と三つに分けて説明しましたけど
善根の場合はそういう三つの分け方がないんです
大体人はこの無知がなくなったら
その代わりに智慧がある場合は
大体いいことはするんです
で 無知がなくなっても
大体欲がなくなる場合はいくらでもありますね
自分でものをもらおうもらおうということじゃなくて
たまにまあものをあげようという気持ちになる時もよくあるし
人を嫉妬したりするだけではなくて
人に優しくしようではないかと
なんかいろんな自然やら人々のことやら考えたらすごく気持ちよくなっている時もよくあるし
そういう場合はまあ善根なんですね
ですから むさぼりが消えちゃったら
そこは善根が生まれる
怒りが消えちゃったらそこで善根が生まれる
で 一般の人々にとってはこのむさぼりはなかなか消えません
それ置き換えなくちゃいけないですね
他の心性で ですから この例えばむさぼりのパーリ語ではローバというんですね
で いつの心にはむさぼりがありまして
好きなものっていくんだから
たまにアローバにもなる場合はあるんですね
で ローバは貪でアローバは不貪なんですね
よくこの仏教は このヨーロッパ的な
この理解するしようとすると
特に英語の英語のテキストなんか読むと
あのちょっとした問題なんですけど
例えばロードはグレートと言って greatですね
そこでアローバは何ですか？といきなりノングレート翻訳しなくちゃいけないんですね
で なんかこの論理的にはちょっとなんか成り立たないというか
例えば白いという色があるならば
それの反対に黒いという色があるんではないかと
仏教的な考え方は白いと非白いなんですね
ただ非入れるだけで 負入れるだけで
あれはどういう考え方ですかと
そこにちょっとまあもうそこそこまあ丁寧に考えないと理解できないところなんですけど
で 私たちの心に 例えばすごく欲の心がある場合は
簡単に欲が消えないんです
欲を消えるためには 逆に施しという感情が与えようという感情が生まれなきゃ消えないんです
そうすると 我々にとっては与えることもポジティブな行動なんです
でも 貪と不貪といえば
不貪はポジティブ的じゃないんです
否定的なんですね 言葉自体は
で 言葉はありますよ 老婆の代わりにアローバではなく
例えばダーナという言葉がありまして
パリッチャラという言葉がありまして
一応パーリ語で言葉自体いろいろありますよ
このダーナっていうのは
この  [音楽]自分の方から自分がもう心のエネルギーっていうのを自分の方向に引っ張るエネルギーばっかりなんですね
見るものは自分のものにしたいし
聞くものは自分のものにしたいと
だからこちらで自分という幻想を作っちゃって
外はこちらに引っ張る引っ張るしたいんですね
それはあり得ない話なんです
できないものなんですね
私はここで太陽の宇宙は自分のところに引っ張らせたっても
自分が死ぬしか結果がない
苦しむしか 例えばですから
外の大きな世界は自分の中に引っ張るするのを苦しみの元なんですね
でも心はそういう風に外から中に引っ張るように精神的なエネルギーが出てくるんですね
それは老婆と言うんですね
それから苦しみが生まれてくるんだと
わかりやすく言えば 例えば大きな木があるんだと
それ見たらすごい綺麗なんですね
そこで引っ張って持っていこうと思っちゃうと
自分が苦しむだけなんですね
それ引っ張ってうちの中に持っていけませんだから
何でも自分の方向へ尾行すると
そこに苦しみが確実に生まれる
そこに行くものが大きければ大きいほど自分が壊れる
だから むさぼりは苦しみの元という論理になっちゃうんですね
小さなもの 例えばこれぐらいのこの缶ジュースぐらいのものだったら
これもらおうと思ったら
もういくらか重いだけのことね
そんなに苦しみないかもしれませんだけど
この建物自体私のものにしようと思って引っ張っちゃったら
誰が死ぬんですか？引っ張る自分が死ぬんで
建物はそのまんまなんですね
で 我々は眼耳鼻舌身意に入る全ての世界を自分のものにしようとしているんです
ですから 確実に不幸を味わうはずなんです
むさぼりから そこでこの元に引っ張る
自分の方向へ引っ張るエネルギーは逆にすると外へ出すと
確実に幸福になるという論理なんです
ですから 美しい公園は自分の内の中に引っ張るんじゃなくて
自分が公園の方に行けば楽しいんです
何の苦しみもないんです
綺麗な木を見たら これ綺麗な木だから私もそれ一つ欲しいんだとかね
これ持っていくことじゃなくて
綺麗な木だな そこで見ておけば楽しいんであって
苦しみがそこに生まれませんね
ですからその自分に向いてる精神的エネルギーを外へ向けば
もう簡単なことなんですね
ですから その場合はポジティブ的な行動なんですね
それ わかりやすく言うならば
施しなさいというのがわかりやすい言葉で
心理学的にはそんな簡単じゃないんです
一般的には あなた方はお布施しなさい
施しなさいと ということだけで
社会福祉活動しなさいとかね
で それで間違えてすごい威張っちゃうんで
私はいいことをしているんではないかとかね
施しをしているんではないかとか思っちゃうと
また自我が出てきて またエネルギーが逆になって
外から内のようになってしまっちゃうんですね
ですからこの そこはもうあまりこの強調
しすぎてね 施しやいろんなものは
やっぱり心理 心の働きとしては
このすごく複雑な働きで
自分の方から外へエネルギーを出すという
それで必ず幸福になるし
リラックスしちゃうし
楽しくなってしまっちゃうんですね
いわゆるもっと分かりやすく言えば
この他人から結果をね
求めない行為なんですね
例えば自分が仕事をする
仕事をして褒めてもらいたいなと思っちゃったら
確実に苦しみがあるんですね
褒めても褒めなくても
どうでも自分がやらなくちゃことだからやってしまうんだと
それで終わったと もう終わったと思っちゃえば
もう向こうはけなしてもこちらは別に楽しいし
褒めてもこちら別にどうってことない
楽しいし だから幸福な状態に守られるんですね
そういう働きで とにかく貪りの反対の言葉として不貪という言葉を仏教は使っていて
もう一般の人々はポジティブ的な行動をしない限りは
不貪の心は生まれません
ですから 例えば嘘を言わないという戒律があるんですね
何もしなきゃいいです
それだけのことでしょう
なんか楽に考えちゃうかもしれません
でもそちらにポジティブ的な行動入ってるんですね
やっぱり喋るたびに真実
意味のあること 人の役に立つことを定期的に喋らないといけないんですね
例えば私は嘘を言わない戒律は一生守りますよと思って一生口をきかないようにすると守られますよ
それでもしゃべりたくなるならば
手術でもして音が出ないようにしてもらえば
この人は一生嘘を言わない戒律をよく守ったんだと
すごい徳が高いんだと
何のこともないんです
それだったら ポジティブ的な行動を何もやってないんだから
ですから 何かポジティブ的なことをやらない限りは
いいことをしたことにならない
それが一般のレベルなんですね
でも仏教は悟りを喋ってますから
ポジティブ的な行動っていうのはそんなにたくさんあるわけじゃないんです
決まってるんです 世の中で
無料にあるわけじゃないんですね
ですから まず貪りの心は施しによって改善していきます
それからもっとさらに貪が消える状態にする
それで貪が消えた状態には量がないんですね
貪を消しちゃったら そこにはもう無料の心なんですね
だから不貪という言葉を使っているんです
施しという言葉を使わないで
施しと言った途端もう制限を決められちゃうんですね
人のエネルギーがあります
そのエネルギーに頼れるぐらいの施しかできませんだからね
そうするとカルマはもう決まっちゃうんですね
例えば怒りあって不瞋という逆の言葉あるでしょ
それではいいんです 正しいんです
その怒りの反対は慈悲ですからね
じゃあ私は慈悲の行動をしますよと言ったら
慈悲っていうのは自分のこの脳細胞の心で
どれぐらいの人々に生命慈悲できるかということがもう決まってるんですね
自分の能力は ですから無料にならない
ですから怒りを消すという言葉を使ってるんですね
ちょっと説明がちょっと難しいんだけど
大変なことを考えて こういう否定形を使っているんです
ただ簡単に楽々と言っているわけじゃないんです
ですから この仏教の説法するね
まあ人々はものすごい簡単に
仏教は簡単だ 不貪瞋痴やりますし
それは不貪瞋痴やればああだこうだとね
そんなに聞くときに気持ち悪いんですね
何もわかってないということは
もう私一番聞きたくない説法なんですね
何もわかってないと すぐわかるんで
偉そうに口だけでね 舌だけ動かして喋ってるだけだと
そういうものじゃないんです
すっごいこのすごい深い意味があるんです
例えばあるところで涅槃は説明してください
質問されたところで お釈迦様は不貪瞋愚痴は涅槃であると
そこをもう頭の一番発展していない脳細胞だけ使って
ああそうかと まあ涅槃というのはわかりましたと
わかるわけないでしょうに
不貪瞋愚痴は涅槃であると言っただけで
貪りはわかるかもしれません
怒りがわかるかもしれませんだけど
そこはもう消えた状態をわかったわけじゃないんですね
ですから この不入れているのは
このリミットを隠すなくすためなんです
ですから 例えばこれは分かりやすい
例えば白いと それの反対の反対言葉何でしたっけ？白いと黒いではなくて
それね 不でも無でもいいんですけどね
入れたら量が多いでしょ
白いものでものは全部入ってるでしょ
だから全部まとめちゃうんです
その記入ることによって
白いと黒いというのはもう 2つ決まってるんです
白いと黒いというのは
赤も青も入りませんでしょ
白い色とそうで